[Music]
hey Blake what your girlfriend sitting
next to me when Stefani is back on the
voice her first time returning to the
show since going public with her
relationship with Blake Shelton the no
doubt front woman made it clear she has
no issue using her bow as a selling
point with contestants used my thing
with him to influence you because that
means you got double like double pal I
don't but she's also down for a little
friendly competition the first just say
something right now Wow
just as you have on a cowboy belt please
I really want to just talk to you for a
second before he does the only thing we
love seeing more than cute Gwen and
Blake moments is cute when Blake and
Adam moments I just think that you're
meant to be on Gwen's team of course you
do you have no choice but to think that
et recently sat down with all four
coaches of the singing competition show
one and Blake opened up about mixing
business with pleasure
do you and him team up on an alliance at
all do you help each other out do you
think they do
yes yeah I think a little peep I think a
little bit I have some help I mean we we
do talk about it like on off days and
then all of a sudden she's are quite a
minute talking to you about
you